foreign
wait what where am I I just had the
worst dream this critically acclaimed
show wasted an entire episode on a
boring side quest but since we're back
to Hopper I guess I just blacked out for
a while
Mother of God I sincerely hope not yeah
Hopper I think you should get even
closer to the glass here
it's polycarbon I think it can't get
through making definitive statements
about the demon creature that just
crawled out of an interdimensional
hellhole mother Mary okay they're kind
of adorable but let's not go naming them
just yet and getting Overly Attached
also I understand invoking the name of
Saint Mary I mean she apparently popped
out a kid without getting to do the fun
stuff required to make one but Joseph
why are you invoking his name he's such
a boring character that the gospels just
stopped talking about him after Jesus
turned 12. invoke someone cooler next
time like John or Goku look it's been a
while since I attended Sunday school but
I think he was canonized as a saint
right
we need to make will sleep how does Mike
know which needle to grab
aha I see someone in the upside down
taught these dimmick organs how to use
elevators also this is why you don't use
elevators in an emergency this exact
reason do you know who I am
your your mom hold him down oh I'm so
sorry possessed will you were close but
the answer we were looking for was
actually mom yes yes I know almost
indistinguishable from your answer but
TV moms can just tell the difference you
know how the [__] did Joyce know how
much of that to give her son did she
receive training and anesthesia when she
got a job at the grocery store
polycarbonate glass no problem steel
hatch easy peasy wooden door gonna need
a bit more time on this one I see
someone in the upside down DOT it's
demigorgons how to use elevators and
shut off the power to advance government
facilities they thought of everything
this is not the logo Sears used in 1984.
oh turns out it is the logo they used in
1984. well here's the sin for the amount
of time you spend getting this right
instead of coming up with a proper
adventure for 11. just pick a cent Billy
if you're going for that rustic ashtray
musk don't muddle it with cologne isn't
that right
yes sir no I want to hate Billy because
he's an [__] yeah in the background
he's being abused by a piece of Father
then this makes this situation morally
complex then I have to try to understand
why he's the way he is how dare you
write well-rounded [__] and before
you ask yes if they hadn't developed
anymore I'd have seen the lack of making
him a well-rounded [__] I can do both
because I actually am a well-rounded
[__] you're positive that was dark
yes you had the same exact yellow
pattern on his butt convenient genetic
blemish is extremely convenient molted
shed his skin to make room for more
growth like hornworms the [__] is
hornworm you know what common animals
molt crabs and snakes why not use an
example everyone can understand Dustin
you pretentious little when's he gonna
molt again It's gotta be soon
when he does he'll be fully grown or
close to it Dustin speaking with an
Attenborough level of confidence about
the life cycle of the hell spawn walking
nightmare maw that he just met we both
broke the rule of law okay so we're
eating we're even this is like trying to
get the judge to also give the cop who
chased you a speeding ticket not sure
that's gonna hold up in broke or Dustin
no no hey hey guys why are you headed
towards the sound Maxine would be the
maddest Max at TV sins if you want to
unlock the doors you have to completely
reboot the computer system and then
override the security codes with a
manual input find how do I do that you
can't unless you know basic Bob doesn't
appear to realize there's a chasmatic
difference between knowing how to code
and knowing how the security system of a
super secret government laboratory Works
don't worry Bob I'm sure the plot has no
idea either and will back you all the
way remember Bob newbie
Bob Newby ill-fated emotional chew toy
strangely they're not in there are they
we're not sure
why
don't worry about answering Dustin some
roaring demogorgons with perfect
dramatic timing are here to save you the
energy also with how loud these things
are it's a wonder they sneak up on
anyone at all they're like demon Huskies
but somehow less whiny
this jump scaring pipe is a dick to Bob
the audience and my poor cat that I just
reflexively kicked into the Year 2038.
let me try no let me try Jonathan trying
the exact same thing as the guy before
you and expecting different results
pretty sure a dude named Einstein called
that insanity or something I don't know
I haven't seen Oppenheimer yet is it
embarrassing that he forgot the gun yes
but that's not what this thing is for
the sin is the fact that the show is
treating him like it matters when the
guns do nothing to the demo dogs because
of course they don't they did there'd be
no series because this show is set in
America why the [__] is hop carrying
will and the gun that kind of seems like
a bad idea if he has to use it can't
Joyce and Mike help what else are they
carrying at this point besides emotional
trauma stop what what what do you think
Bob he's not asking you to stop because
there's a banana peel on the floor my
dude you're almost home free all right
Bob condemning Bob to certain death with
one sentence yeah this is a good place
to rest and reunite nice and safe
and to prove my point from earlier
here's Hopper putting several rounds
into one of these things while it barely
flinches didn't even ruin its appetite
okay I get there eating him because it's
awful and the only reason they cast Sean
Aston is to make us cry thanks for that
by the way but why are they eating him
really they didn't stop to snack on any
of the other victims they just killed
they had everyone probably would have
had time to escape why do the fictional
beelza pups want my tears if you guys
know that Bob was the original founder
of Hawkins AV creating a backstory for a
character after they're dead to make
them being dead sadder we can't let him
die anything according to Mike saving
Joyce Hopper will and you Mike qualifies
as dying in vain so how do you kill this
thing shoot it with Fireballs or
something as if the Mind flare has 90
magic resistance you're not gonna do
Fireballs you can just shoot this with
guns you don't know that we literally do
know that you yourself shot several with
a gun and it did nothing you know it's
already killed everybody in that lab you
don't know that Mike what about Dr Owens
after what happened to Bob do you really
think this show is going to kill him off
screen and miss the opportunity for
another graphic and emotional punch to
our still weeping husks Also let's talk
about how awful their evacuation plan
must have been for five dog creatures to
kill everyone especially considering
there was a point after the alarm
sounded when all of them were in a
slow-moving freight elevator did they
even run drills he can't spy if he
doesn't know where he is does he need to
know you've literally taken him back to
his [__] house if the being on the
other side of this can't deduce that
their family home was a possible
destination then I don't think you need
to worry about them being much of a
threat just because you know the truth
it doesn't mean you're in our party I'm
so tired of Mike being a petty little
head to Max making your character start
off by hating each other doesn't make me
any happier when they eventually end up
becoming friends just means you've made
me feel more feelings than I needed to
I'm just saying L she sounds like she
was really awesome so awesome that she's
basically sidelined for an entire Fire
season while babering stapling injecting
other various montaging excitement also
this feels like a lot of work to hide
your location when a really good
blindfold would have gotten the job done
if he finds out where we are will we
send those dogs after us he won't find
out making definitive statements about
the owner of the demon creatures that
live on the other side of the
interdimensional hellhole they climbed
out of
out with me to Mel vaults and I put it
up I told everyone who came in
my son Drew this and I'm sure they were
just as Overjoyed by that picture as
they were by the baby pictures you
showed them or that dream you had last
night and chose to describe in
unnecessary amounts of detail I'm so
proud skip do you remember that your dad
left
first I thought we met
scofoli Bob was here to recode my skip
button it was the best thing I've ever
done asking a kid to be your friend in
kindergarten was the best thing you've
ever done peaked real early there didn't
you Mike what is that Morse code once
again it's time to play are You Smarter
Than Steve Harrington yes yes you
probably are but your hair is probably
worse
phone it could be anywhere
right right if it wasn't the phone at
Will's house because you morons have no
imagination there's a whole specialized
team of doctors whose sole job it is to
put people under but hey I'm sure Joyce
randomly stabbing will where she feels
like will be just fine holy [__] is it
dead Hopper deciding to use his boots
instead of his bullets to check if the
malevolent Venus Man Trap from another
reality is dead Deuce X11 uh again again
again again again
okay also Lucas looks so disappointed it
must have been his dream to go out
wielding a plastic slingshot also while
also hey why does why does L look so
different so weird she looks just like
she did in that dream I have oh no it
wasn't a dream was it they really did
waste an entire episode on her going to
Chicago didn't they no
[Music]
also no
Mash'Em stick him in a stew
art
oh Jesus Christ
compels you
we're gonna go must go faster shed his
skin to make room for more growth like
horn worms didn't I just tell you to
stop making up animals Steve Nancy
Jonathan donkey okay Bob can you hear us
hey Tugger nuts I've got you on
speakerphone it's like in the great
stories Mr Frugal for ones that really
mattered full of darkness and danger
they were and sometimes you didn't want
to know the end because how could the
end be happy I think he's talking
it's not with the words don't wait for
the translation answer me now